everyone only has the same hours of the  day if that's the case anybody who only  sleeps eight hours and works the  remaining of hours of the day all of  them would be tied for hardest working  so once you max out your hours worked  there has to be another variable which  is the leverage you gain on the  activities and the time you spend and  that is in my opinion where people  should focus their attention if you're a  newbie and you can't get your ass off  the couch and by all means figure out  how to actually get your ass off the  couch and do stuff but once you have  tapped that out very quickly you hit  your capacity of work and so in order to  increase your capacity you must increase  the leverage you have on the activities  you do what if some an activity has a  hundred times higher leverage do I still  need to work 16 hours a day so then the  reality is that you just need to figure  out the activities that have the most  leverage and do those